in Deutschland breitet sich leider eine
chronische die da oben machen doch eh
was Sie wollen Stimmung aus immer mehr
von uns ziehen sich zurück in die
Meckerecke das ist ja so was also tun
okay einmittel wären vielleicht neue
Formen der Bürgerbeteiligung mehr
direkte Demokratie genau das ist wohl
die Idee hinter dem Bürgerrat der gerade
vom Bundestag eingesetzt wurde gab's so
noch nie 160 Bürger beraten bis Ende
Februar über das Thema Ernährung
ausgerechnet Ernährung wir will uns den
noch alles vorschreiben was wir zu
futtern haben hier der Volksmund mal
vertreten durch einen vorbestraften
würstchenfabrikanten geht über diese
Bevormundung die
alle mir vorschreiben will dass ich kein
Zucker mehr Kaffee tun
soll natürlich ja natürlich
natürlichte mir persönlich kontrolliert
jeden Morgen Asse ja natürlich als
nächstes zwingen die Grünen den höhes
wahrscheinlich noch Steuern zu zahlen ja
wo leben wir denn wo leben wir denn gut
der Bürgerrat tut garantiert keimem was
in den Kaffe stattdessen diskutieren sie
da beraten von Experten Themen wie
Kennzeichnungspflicht für Lebensmittel
wichtig oder Tierhaltung ja Tierhaltung
gerade in deutschen Stellen ist da
durchaus noch Luft nach oben bzw ganz
wenig Luft wie werden denn die neuen
bürgerräte so gehalten ein großes Hotel
hat die Bundestagspräsidentin anmieten
lassen im Keller neben dem Parkhaus wird
nun getagt
hey coole Location oder ja und die
nächste Tagung findet dann neben dem
Pfandautomaten im Penny statt die 160
bürgerräte und Rätinnen werden per
Losverfahren bestimmt und dabei wird
wohl drauf geachtet dass die den
Querschnitt der Bevölkerung
repräsentieren ne nach Geschlecht Alter
Bildungsstand Fleischesser Vegetarier
etc meine wenn wir das znächst öfter so
machen dann kommt nach den Tagesthemen
immer die Ziehung der bürgerräte 160 aus
83 Millionen also auch gesela aus Erfurt
ist mit dabei und unser zusatzbürgerrat
diese Woche der Oliver aus Köln
herzlichen Glückwunsch ach du scheiße
passt mir überhaupt nicht Experten
meinen solche gelosten grämien könnten
eine Lücke
zwischen klassischer Parteipolitik und
Bürgerinitiativen in Irland hat der
sogenannte citizens Assembly die
großkonflikte Abtreibung und
gleichgeschlechtliche Ehe erfolgreich
entschärft nach dem Motto mitmachen
statt einfach nur wütend sein wobei muss
man dazuagen schon bei der ersten
athenischen Volksversammlung als quasi
die Demokratie erfunden wurde stand ja
nur wenige Meter entfernt direkt die
ersten gechischen Wutbürger mit
periklismus wegschildern ein hatte sogar
eine russische Fahne dabei gab's
Russland da noch gar g nicht es ist
verrückt verrückt so aber wie geht's
jetzt weiter mit dem Bürgerrat Ernährung
wenn die fertig sind mit beraten
übergeben Sie Ihre Empfehlungen dem
Deutschen Bundestag und die Politik kann
dann im Prinzip damit machen was sie
will das ist alles völlig unverbindlich
und sicher klüger wäre auch was davon
umzusetzen damit das ganze nicht als
pseudobürgerbeteiligung endet
tatsächlich ist aber selbst das bisschen
Beteiligung manchen schon zu viel diese
wütenden cdurentner z.B in der
repräsentativen Demokratie steht das
Parlament im Mittelpunkt und das darf
nicht relativiert werden jetzt ist nicht
die Zeit für eine Delegitimierung der
Parlamente mon pleps der ohne jeden
lobbyeinfluss einfach irgendwas
diskutiert nicht mal für Geld wo kommen
wir denn dahin fragt Marie am
tornett dabei hat die CDU Legende
Wolfgang Schäuble den Bürgerrat doch
damals angeschoben jetzt tut seine
Partei plötzlich so als wäre das der Tod
der parlamentarischen Demokratie hier
warnvideo ein ausgeloster Querschnitt
der Bevölkerung darf über Ernährung
diskutieren gewöhnliche Menschen die im
Supermarkt arbeiten oder auf dem Bau
vielleicht sogar
Arbeitslose absoluter Wahnsinn bleiben
wir also lieber beim bewrten System das
heißt eine Landwirtschaftsministerin
empfängt den nestley Chef und der sagt
ihr dann was die Deutschen fressen
sollen EU denn mit Essen spielt man
nicht hat sich
bewährt hat sich doch so
bewrt okay zur Klarstellung natürlich
ersetzen bürgerräte nicht ein Parlament
die sollten auch kein Vetorecht haben
wie das z.B der letzten Generation
vorschwebt aber man darf ja auch mal die
Chancen von sowas sehen wo trifft man
denn in unserem polarisierten Land sonst
noch Leute mit einer anderen Meinung
sowas kann ja auch die
gesellschaftlichen Konflikte
befrieden katjana GZ leitet im Bürgerrat
erernährung die Arbeitsgruppe Tierwohl
heute hält sie einen Vortrag über
haltungsstufen das heißt
86% vom supermarktfleisch ist
haltungsstufe 1 oder 2 also Stallhaltung
das muss man sich erstmal vorstellen wie
das für einen selber wäre so den ganzen
Tag in so einem Stall absolut das ist
eine Riesensauerei sag mal du ist jetzt
nicht beef während ich über Tierwohl
rede ja sorry ich Binter
das ist super gefährlich ah ja
jedenfalls bei Hühnern sieht ja so aus
Freilandhaltung nimmt zwar zu aber wir
haben immer noch über 60% bodenhal
weshalb der Gesetzgeber sag mal wo hast
du jetzt in so kurzer Zeit KFC einal her
farando wichtig ist uns dass man im
Gespräch bleibt auch beim Thema
Ernährung ist Deutschland inzwischen so
gespalten dass gar keine Kommunikation
mehr stattfindet völlig korrekt das sehe
ich genauso K vielen Dank moment mal sie
sind aber kein Lobbyist von nessle
oder kurz darauf eskaliert die Situation
und zwar über die Frage was man zum
Abendessen
bestellt
do Partei vi mit hühchenal mit Tofu ist
Gluten
drin nur Minuten spter
hab
vegetar Veganer pesetarier und natürlich
die Paleo Fans die ihr Fleisch wie in
der Steinzeit essen wir brechen für
heute ab das hat so keinen Sinn mehr ich
gehe jetzt erstmal nach Hause damit wir
morgen hoffentlich wirklich in Innenraum
Kohlenmonoxidvergiftung das ist genau
diese grüneevormundung die den Leuten so
auf Sack geht vielleicht habe ich
einfach Bock auf Kohlenmonoxidvergiftung
kann sein mach doch mir egal gute Nacht
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an und
abonniert den Kanal
danke schaut euch gerne weitere Videos
an und abonniert den Kanal danke
oh nein eine Zeitschleife habt ihr etwa
nicht den Kanal abonniert Hilfe sofort
drauf klicken oder ich bin hier für
immer
ge schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an